look I've got to say something in
defense of Mitt Romney here he's
catching a lot of flak because it's been
revealed of course that he had that fake
a fake Twitter account that and in fact
the only reason we know about that I
guess is because he told on himself he
admitted that he has a fake account and
then people were able to find out which
account it is based on context clues and
it turns out that he's got this fake
account and the fakes accounts name is
Pierre de lecto which is a just a
delectable name for a fake account if I
if I do say so myself
and the his account his alter ego peered
Alecto would often compliment and defend
Mitt Romney and and so people are making
fun of him for that but I've got to come
to Romney's defense much like Pierre de
lecto would do and say that I don't
blame Romney for having fake accounts I
have fake accounts myself I have many
fake accounts but the only difference is
that my fake accounts have turned
against me and now they all insult me
and and troll me just like everybody
else
single-tier goes down the cheek at least
my point is at least Romney's alter ego
is loyal to him and that's gotta count
for something I think that speaks to a
man's character when your alter egos
because think about it I you know it you
think about how sort of close quarters
you are with your alter ego you're
sharing a brain and it can be really
difficult to to maintain a good working
relationship and the fact that he has is
is is I think speaks to it by the way
remember
Trump's has an alter ego his alter egos
John Baron and so John Baron used to
back in the old days in New York he used
to call up the media with flattering
stories about Donald Trump um now I'll
tell you though so now this debate has
started about who who's better
which one do you prefer Pierre de lecto
or John Baron and I gotta say they both
have their plus sides they both have
their weaknesses and their flaws just
like any just like any other alter ego
what it would have but I I tend to
prefer John Baron just because I like
how John Baron more forward you know
he's gonna call you on the phone and and
he's gonna get in front of it
and he's it's John Baron he's not just
playing defense oh then he's on offense
so what peered Alecto would do is he
just gonna defend Mitt Romney against
attack whereas John Baron he's gonna go
and say I'm gonna plant good stories
about about about my friend Donald and
so I prefer that here's what I really
want to see though I want to see a
televised event debate between Donald
Trump Mitt Romney John Barron and peered
Alecto that's what that's what we need
to see so somebody get on that that is
pay-per-view material right there
if pay-per-view even existed anymore it
really doesn't alright much to discuss
today beginning with a sex scandal a
pretty let's say remarkable sex scandal
in in many ways a sex scandal involving
a prominent politician one one one that
even has accompanying photographs okay
yet so it's got all the makings for a
big splash type story but you probably
haven't heard about it
the media has already successfully
buried it which tells you that this was
a Democrat of course obviously but
anytime there's a sex scandal involving
a politician and and you hadn't and you
hadn't heard about it you know the the
story broke a week ago and you're just
hearing about it now or a few days ago
then you automatically know that it's a
Democrat um but there are other reasons
why this scandal is being conspicuously
ignored and I want to talk about that in
just a moment but first a word from
policy genius you know Halloween is on
the way which means it's time to break
out the rubber spiders the fake cobwebs
the jack-o'-lanterns we've got we've got
all that stuff in our house right now
especially with with my kids or fixed
spiders and everything everywhere which
I saw someone on Twitter point out the
the irony that you know you you you're
you clear out the real cobwebs so that
you can put the fake cobwebs up in their
place I don't know it's just something
that we do as human beings in modern
society but if you've got a family
you might be dealing with something a
little bit scarier right now which is
shopping for life insurance if the idea
of looking for life insurance
intimidates you which I know it can for
me then you got to try policy genius.com
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for life insurance online in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape and that's
and that's for me that's the main thing
is that it's kind of intimidating when
you think about something like life
insurance all of the paperwork and
everything all the hoops you got to jump
through well you go to policy genius and
they're gonna make it really easy for
you
this October take the scariness out of
buying life insurance with policy genius
go to policy genius calm get quotes and
apply in minutes you can do the whole
thing on your phone right now policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance all right
representative Katie Hill
congresswoman from California of course
Democrat influential prominent serves on
two important committees of the
Oversight Committee and armed and
service our armed services armed and
service so that's three committees she's
on the oversight the armed and then the
service good anyway Armed Service
Committee and the over Sigma according
to read state which originally reported
this based on their doing this based on
on information they were provided
through text messages and photographs so
they they've got the goods
and what they're reporting is that
representative Hill was allegedly
involved in a sexual relationship with a
22 year old female staffer and then she
was allegedly in an affair with another
person that worked for her this time a
man plus she was married the whole time
okay so this is this yes this is
something like out of a soap opera but
but real life allegedly so let's take a
look at this I'm gonna read some key
portions from the report in red state
here's what red state says photographs
and text messages obtained by red states
show that representative Hill
was involved in a long-term sexual
relationship with a female campaign
staffer the woman whose name is not
being released was hired by Hill in late
2017 and quickly became involved in a
throuple throuple relationship with Hill
and her estranged husband Kenny Heslop
Heslop and the staffer according to text
messages provided shred State believe
the polyamorous arrangement to be a
long-term committed relationship
the trio took multiple vacations
together including to Alaska where this
photograph was taken and then they
provide a photograph Hill broke it off
eventually and there are there are text
messages showing this back and forth
between her and the staffer where Hill
admits that at least part of her reason
for breaking it off is that it's a
politically dangerous thing for her to
be doing then which it turns out it
actually wasn't because the media is not
paying attention and doesn't care um and
then that's around the time when her
husband found out that Hill had also
allegedly been an affair with her
finance director I guess at the same
time um so she she was getting she was
really getting around allegedly she was
she was sleeping with everybody at the
office allegedly and and then that's
that's when the husband broke it off so
I guess the husband is saying hey I know
you were involved in a sexual
relationship with with this other person
at work that was fine but then but then
a second person know that crosses a line
that's that's over the line okay you
know we want to you want to be sexually
involved with with two people fine three
no allegedly that's what that's the way
that that worked out now as I said there
are text messages some of which are
published by red state you can go check
those out there are also photos one
which I won't put up on the screen for
you but it's online where it appears to
be Hill naked and brushing the hair of a
young female whose hair whose face is
blurred out presumably it is these the
staffer in question very weird very
creepy
so a few
first is any of this relevant to the
public does it matter
or is it all just gossip now I would say
it does matter
certainly here's here's the stipulation
according to the standards applied to
other public figures and politicians
usually Republicans it does matter and
here's why first of all Katie was was
Katie Hill was allegedly involved with
somebody who was a subordinate a staffer
just fresh out of college
now the me2 movement has always insisted
unless I'm hallucinating I'm pretty sure
the me2 movement has been saying for
years now that a power dynamic like that
is tantamount to assault that's not
really my standard that's I didn't come
up with that that's what the me2
movement has been saying that when
you've when you've got a power dynamic
where it's a subordinate with with their
with their boss and I think if you add
in political power that the boss has on
top of that just normal empower power
that that someone above someone else in
a working environment would have then
then as the logic goes the subordinate
can't really consent because they're not
going to feel totally free to operate in
the relationship the way that they would
if if the person was equal to them in
power now personally I'm not sure that I
agree with this idea all the time I
think that it sort of depends but but
we're not talking about my opinion here
we're talking about the standard that is
normally applied we're talking about the
logic that has been the driving force
for the me2 movement keep in mind that
many of the me2 stories were not cases
of forcible rape some of them were but
but many of them weren't a lot of the
times it was it was you know these were
powerful men having having what appeared
to be ostensibly consensual encounters
with women but the women did not feel
they say free to to refuse because of
the power these men had over
in in the industry and so the men were
exploiting that power and again
according to the me2 movement that's
basically rape it's basically sexual
assault well how is this any different
if that's the standard how is this any
different it isn't and the picture of
hill brushing the hair naked I mean it's
just it's creepy and it shows exactly
this kind of dynamic where we're you
know Hill sitting naked in a chair the
girl sitting on the floor having her
hair brushed it shows this very weird
creepy power dynamic on top of all that
her female lover was being paid by
campaign funds so there's all kinds of
issues being raised there and that also
makes it a public concern and in
addition she was as I said on two
important committees so yet she's having
affairs with with with all these people
who she works with and and there are
pictures and that sets her up for
blackmail makes her vulnerable to
manipulation and coercion which makes it
a potential national security issue and
yet predictably despite those three
factors which which make this a
according to normal standards make this
a relevant story and would you would
think make this a big story yet
predictably the story is getting no play
I mean none at all even less than I
thought when I saw this story on Friday
I I knew of course that it's not gonna
make it into the headlines on CNN it
won't even be reported by CNN or NBC
right but I it's getting even less play
than I thought even in conservative
media people are leaving this thing
alone it's just yet it's just no one's
talking about it aside from red state
and a couple other websites I saw I saw
a report on on Breitbart I think the
Washington Examiner had it but other
than that it's been it's been radio
silence it's been buried why is that
well obviously because Hill is a
Democrat that's one of the reasons
that's a big factor but even more so I
think it's because
a woman and women can get away with this
kind of stuff all day long women are
simply not held to the same standard as
men when it comes to sexual
improprieties
you're just you're not gonna see ever
the kind of outrage when it's a woman
who is the sexual aggressor or the you
know the person who's in the
exploitative position in the in a
position of power or whatever when it
comes to any kind of sex scandal thing
when when the woman is the is the the
culprit it's just never ever going to
engender the kind of outrage it does
with men ever perfect example would be
all of these stories about female
teachers I've talked about it many times
but but no one cares all these stories
of female teachers you want to talk
about exploiting your power over someone
well that's really clear-cut you're an
adult you're a teacher this is a kid and
you are you are exploiting that position
to get your sexual thrills with a minor
that's that's that's wrong that's
criminal that's sudden and when it's
happening all over the place all the
time in public school you think it would
be we'd be treating it like an epidemic
and talking about nobody cares
we just we just say that you know
whatever so women get away with this
stuff can you imagine just imagine now I
know you don't want to really imagine it
so try to just just try to try to
imagine the hypothetical without
actually imagining the picture itself
but but you think about if there was a
picture of a of a male Congress man
naked and brushing the hair of a young
female staffer can you just think about
that for a second and here's the thing
it could be a Democrat I don't even
think it even now obviously if it was a
Republican and be getting even more
attention but even if it was a Democrat
I think it would still be getting
certainly more attention in this story
is that image that photo would be this
iconic thing that everybody sees and it
would be referred
- ten years from now people would still
remember yet it's a woman so nobody
cares also the fact that it's a
homosexual thing I think helps her so so
Hill has three things going for her and
that make this untouchable even her if
her staffers so the story is untouchable
but as far as Hills concerned apparently
allegedly her staffers are not
untouchable she's uh so she's a woman
she's apparently bisexual and she's a
Democrat and this sets up a dynamic
where she can literally do anything she
wants especially in the area of sex just
whatever it doesn't matter she could do
what she wants no one is ever gonna say
anything she'll get away with it um it's
just it's just completely outrageous and
here's the thing you know I either
either it's true that it's inappropriate
and wrong and even potentially assault
for a person in a position of power to
be involved in a sexual relationship
with someone who's underneath them not
literally but you know either that's
wrong and appropriate potentially
assault or it's not and so you can't
what you do we just can't do this you
make an exception for Katie Hills yeah
you know that whatever then
okay well then you've waived your head
and set your hand and said whatever to
to all of these cases you can't circle
back around the next time there's a
story about a man doing something like
this and say oh look it's the patriarchy
it's sexist I bet saying women are under
attack you just can't do that I mean you
can do it physically no one's gonna stop
you but you can't expect to be taken
seriously when it's entire when it
becomes entirely clear and this has been
this has been my my impression for a
while now a lot of people's impression
the me to movement is more of an anti
male thing it's it's an ideological it's
about it's about smashing the patriarchy
and all this nonsense it's not really
about protecting women or about it's
certainly not about making you know
taking a stand against sexual assault
it's not about that because it's it
know that because it's so damn selective
and it and what the meter movement is
done they've just waved their magic wand
and granted clemency to all women dick
women doesn't matter you're all of you
completely absolved you the dozen
doesn't count doesn't matter you do
whatever you want this is only about men
all right
kind of an awkward transition here I'm
afraid but a brand of menstrual products
well I guess there really is no there's
no non awkward seamless transition from
any subject to talking about mention
products but here we are a brand of
menstrual products the brand always
which is a good name for a brand of
menstrual products I suppose they always
work right better than a brand like
called occasionally or something I have
to stop riffing on Mitchell products
just get to it the point is this brand
has on its packaging the Venus symbol
and it's the circle with a cross beneath
it this is a symbol that universally
means woman which makes sense to have on
your packaging right if you're if it's a
menstrual thing because because it's a
menstrual product so you've got a symbol
that represents people who men straight
makes a lot of sense you would think
well trans activists were not happy
about it because they they came in the
trans activists did and they made the
point that sometimes men men straight
just like sometimes polar bears fly
sometimes squirrels do calculus these
things happen anything's happen there
are there are no rules
science is a myth and that's how it is
and Proctor and Gamble which owns the
brand always and is a big massive huge
scary corporation they own approximately
every brand at the grocery store but
they caved to the complaints of these of
these gender confused at individuals and
said okay we'll take the symbol off and
they did because an enormous
multinational corporation was bullied
into agreeing that some
men get periods now there was a lot of
talk of menstruating men this weekend
unfortunately because period day also
happened there was the holiday period
day which is a thing I don't know if you
if your celebrated but I guess it's
we're supposed to celebrate periods or
something
yet the trans activists came barging in
yet again as they always do and made the
point that that that actually this
should be about them because that's
always their point isn't it with
anything their point is hey you know
what guys this is really about me isn't
it no matter what you were doing a
matter what we're talking about what the
issue is
they come in barreling in through the
door hey wait a second wait wait wait
wait
let's make this about me and and they
said that so Twitter was filled with a
bunch of people saying hey if we're if
we're doing period day remember men can
get periods now let me give you an
example of one such tweet tweet that I
responded to because I happen to happen
across just one example of someone just
to give you an idea of what people are
saying it says hashtag national period
day remember that says the person said
remember that trans women can get
periods yes
trans women when speaking on the subject
of periods don't live limit the
conversation to sis women only to sis
women only because our trans sisters are
experiencing the same and it's wrong to
cut them out now this is important I
wanted to read that to you because you
need to realize we're taught we're
talking here about and I know this can
get confusing sometimes because all this
gender stuff on the left is madness none
of it makes any sense it's all nonsense
so it's easy to lose track but I want
you to appreciate how insane this is
when someone on the Left says men can
get periods they could be talking about
biological females who identify as men
and yes that's true that those people
can get periods because they aren't
really men and that and that fact that's
kind of the thing that reveals that to
you that's that's the giveaway is
fact that they're having a period which
means they're I mean if you find
yourself in a situation where you're
having a period it means you're not a
man it at least means that so you could
that will clarify that situation for you
and your second clue that you're not a
man is literally everything else about
you literally everything but just to be
clear the left is also claiming that men
biological males actual men can have
periods that's what this tweet and a lot
of people that's what they're saying
when they say trans women can get
periods what they mean is biological
males can men straight that is the claim
and this is a claim that is is basically
mainstream now on the left at least in
the case that now maybe there are a lot
of leftist who won't go out of their way
to go out and announce this they're not
going to go screaming it into a bullhorn
biological males can men straight
they're not going to be screaming that
into the bullhorn but but they're also
not going to deny it
they're not going to argue it biologic
males can men straight now I happen to
get into a back-and-forth with this
particular person on Twitter who wrote
this and they defended their assertion
by saying and I'm not kidding they said
that that that biological males come in
straight because sometimes they get
bloated and they have stomach cramps not
joking that was the argument proving
that biological males come in straight
by saying oh wait what are you saying
that you say the biological males don't
get stomach cramps which is like saying
that a dog is essentially the same as a
tuna because both can swim oh you say a
dog isn't a fish well here's a picture
of my dog swimming our backyard pool
check me science denier it's but what do
you do what when it gets to this point
where you have people sincerely claiming
that biological males can men straight
what what do you what can
there's no argument you can present
because any argument that you do present
is going to be grounded in reality and
what the left is now saying is reality
doesn't matter it simply makes no
difference what the actual reality is so
what can you do well I'll tell you one
thing we can't do is just ignore this
because or treat it as a sideshow or as
an irrelevant issue the left is they are
they are waging a war on reality itself
well that's why when I go to colleges
and I give talks one of the talks I give
is the war on reality this is a war on
reality that's why this matters it's not
just now if this was 20 years ago okay
and you had someone saying biological
males come in straight then yeah you
could you could laugh that off it's out
okay person's crazy it's still crazy but
this
is something that the left is at they
are trying to establish a culture where
that kind of claim is accepted as as
perfectly true and normal so they are
going they're trying to break down
reality itself is that is it worth
fighting back against that yeah I would
say so because if we don't have reality
if words don't mean anything if there's
no reality if science doesn't mean
anything then I even where do we go next
what's what's the point of having any
discussion how do we have any discussion
if we don't have these reference points
based in reality all right I love this I
got a I got a mention it a few weeks ago
the greatest living director Martin
Scorsese a guy who's pushing what is he
80 over 80 now I don't know but he's
still making cinematic classics he's
been doing he's been at it for 30 years
or more 40 years and and nobody in
Hollywood has a batting average like
this guy it really is remarkable a few
weeks ago he came out and said that
Marvel movies are are bad basically said
they don't count as cinema he said
they're more like theme park rides
they're not really movies it's not real
cinema and he's right about that and you
know it brought all the Marvel fans out
to explain how Martin Scorsese doesn't
know what he's talking about he's out of
touch yeah he got this movie the Irish
Man coming out with the De Niro and
Pacino and Pesci and basically all every
great actor has ever been in a mob movie
is gonna be in this movie the Irishman
that's coming out it's got a 100 percent
around tomatoes it says it's his best
reviewed movie ever and this is a guy
who's made nothing but classics almost
he's had a few misses here and there but
you had Marvel Marvel fans sag mad guy
doesn't know anything was he know you
know he's only made almost nothing but
cinematic masterpieces in his career
what does he know about cinema so now I
actually thought I thought that Martin
Scorsese was giving Marvel too much
credit because to say their theme parks
makes them sound at least somewhat
fun in reality they're not even that
they're more they're commercials
Marvel movies if you're going to a
Marvel movie you should understand you
are sitting through a two and a half
hour commercial there they are toy
commercials they exist for the most part
to sell merchandise and they also exist
to propagate themselves they exist so
that another one can exist and that
that's the they're not ever trying to
really tell a story or finish a story or
do anything this is the we want to the
main goal is to sell merchandise with
the movies and so how do we do that what
we need to keep making more and more and
more movies which means the story can
never end there could never be
resolution there could ever be a real
climax or anything like that in the
movie it's just it's not like a
three-act thing it's a typical typical
structure of a story it's just one act
that never ever ever ever ends well this
weekend Francis Ford Coppola
the man behind the greatest film of all
time The Godfather sure I don't have to
tell you he agreed with Scorsese no big
surprise
only he took at fort further he said you
know who's doing a press conference or
something he said what Martin Scorsese
says that the Marvel pictures are not
cinema he's right because we expect to
learn something from cinema we expect to
gain something some enlightenment some
knowledge some information some
inspiration I don't know that anyone
gets anything out of seeing the same
movie over and over again Martin was
kind when he said it's not cinema he
didn't say it's despicable which I say
it is despicable Francis Ford Coppola
said that Marvel movies are despicable I
could not agree more
these movies are they are despicable
because they are actually the most
cynical movies you'll ever watch
don't let the bright colors and the
wisecracks and all that stuff fool you
loud noises and special effects these
are very extremely cynical movies
because it's the movie studio saying we
don't care about the audience we don't
respect your intelligence we don't
respect you we're just gonna we don't we
don't respect the fact that you're
spending money on these tickets and and
so therefore deserve some sort of actual
cinematic experience that's some
what meaningful no we don't care about
that we're just gonna keep shoving the
same tired bland played-out goop down
your gullet s' because we know you'll
swallow it and you'll pay the money and
you'll come back again that's what the
movie studio is saying and you've got
all these people that line up for the
movies and say yes yes please sir can I
have another it is despicable now I
don't mean to appeal to authority here
but but but come on you've got the
greatest living director and now the
director of the greatest film of all
time both saying that these movies are
trash so before you disagree ask
yourself do you know more about cinema
than the greatest living film director
and the director of the greatest movie
ever do you think you know more than
they do
so before you disagree is how you like
Marvel movies maybe there's a who knows
like maybe these guys know a thing or
two maybe they they might be onto
something maybe it's worth considering
you know if if if if if Joe Montana and
Tom Brady were sitting at a bar talking
football and and talking about what they
consider to be the worst football team
in the league would you feel comfortable
coming into that conversation and saying
hey boys hold on you don't know what
you're talking about know that team is
actually good let me explain why I mean
it's look they're not they're not
infallible they could be wrong but these
are guys who are the best experts you're
gonna find in this particular field and
in this case football you've got the two
best quarterbacks ever if they agree on
some football related topic they're
probably right maybe not definitely but
probably all I'm saying is if Scorsese
and Coppola agree on a movie related
topic I'm not gonna disagree because I
think they probably know what they're
talking about but you don't even need to
take their word for it anyway because
because it's it's it should be obvious
you know i-i've been saying this I'm no
movie expert and saying this way before
Scorsese and Coppola chimed in
that these movies are is just the
garbage they really are we should demand
more we should have higher standards and
it's not and please don't say oh well
sometimes it's fun to just turn your
brain off and not every movie needs to
be needs to be thought-provoking oh okay
[ __ ] yeah sure
right but that's not an excuse it even
if yeah not every movie has to be really
deep and thought-provoking that's true I
think it's I think I honestly I think
most ship movies should be I think that
should be sort of the default state of a
movie because it is art and and there
should be a real substantive point to it
but yeah not every movie has to be that
way fine but if you're gonna go the more
lighthearted not even light-hearted
because something could be light-hearted
but still have some depth to it so if
you're gonna go the shallower route
something that's pretty shallow they
could still have creativity it still
have wit there could still be a real
story being told the movie could still
exist for some reason other than simply
to sell merchandise and to propagate its
its itself like some sort of disease so
even in that case there are movies I you
know there are movies I could think of
that that aren't particularly thoughtful
but we're still enjoyable to watch and
still had some creativity to them and
some wit and some you know uniqueness
and and and you could tell that they you
know they exist mainly because the
people involved in the movie wanted to
tell this story you might not be the
most important story in the world but
it's a story and they wanted to tell it
so great but when you have movies where
that that's the I guess this is my point
that's the main reason a movie should
exist now obviously it's got to make
money and and and especially the people
in the movie studios the producers and
everything that's gonna be that their
main concern fine I get that that's the
reality but the Pete the directors and
the actors I mean the main reason and
the person wrote the script and all that
I think
it should be clear from watching it that
what motivated them was the desire to
tell his story that's what makes Martin
Scorsese such a brilliant all-time great
director is that yet he likes making
money definitely that's of course he
does but you also know when he puts a
movie out this is a story he really
wanted to tell and so if he you know so
he might he's begun the movie silence
that came out a few years ago it's like
three hours long this long ponderous
movie about about Portuguese
missionaries in in 16th century Japan
and it wasn't a big blockbuster success
but he spent many years developing this
movie because it's just a story he
wanted to tell I just I don't think with
a Marvel movie you know with when when
Iron Man 15 comes out III just don't
think that anyone involved is really
saying oh we got to tell this this 15th
story about Iron Man where he saves the
day again against some once again saves
a day against some intergalactic guy who
shows up ago whatever you know I don't
think anyone is saying that I think
everyone it I think it's rote and
routine and it's like all right let's
let's let's jump on the the horse again
and and make another billion bucks all
right so I'm gonna go through some
emails and these are exclusively emails
from people challenging me on a number
of subject subjects that I talked about
on the show of course I read and respond
to other emails - I always enjoy emails
that compliment me as well maybe I'll
pull up here delectably I just start
writing them to myself if you won't do
it then I'll do it damn it anyway but
but I also appreciate the back-and-forth
with people who listen and write an
email trying to pick apart my arguments
it die it keeps me sharp relatively at
least as sharp as I can get so this is
from Chad says hi I'm Adam a police
officer in Texas I enjoy your show let
me begin by saying an open structure
calls treated as a burglary if possible
we try to contain the structure on all
sides
you were correct when you said you don't
have all the information I think it's
very difficult for you to make a
cut-and-dried decision as to what should
happen I can only imagine that the guy
was headed to the rear of the building
and saw a person at the window with a
gun I'm not gonna say he's right or
wrong because I don't know all the facts
and you should either my own personal
feeling is that the charge of murder is
a stretch being as he didn't set out to
kill someone
I think manslaughter is more appropriate
the other problem society faces is a
lack of qualified applicants because of
that people are being hired they're
probably not qualified to do a to do to
a lacks and hiring requirements that may
be due to it not being worth it to be a
police officer that may be due to media
coverage or the fact that people are
okay with cops being killed because
quote that's what they signed up for I
hate when people say that because it
cheapens our lives nobody says that
about the military nobody signs up to
die okay Chad first as to this
particular case I agree that the charge
of murder might be a stretch might be a
bit ambitious though honestly I thought
that with the Geiger case - and she was
convicted so who knows I ant but I feel
very confident saying based on what we
know I don't know what's gonna happen in
court or whatever I'm not gonna make any
predictions there but the officer was
very much in the wrong and I think we
know that because these facts are not in
dispute he shot an innocent woman a
law-abiding woman in her home through
the window at two o'clock in the morning
those are the basics facts of the case
now if some other information comes out
that says oh no actually she was a
wanted murderer and she was breaking
into someone's home and you know that's
not gonna happen so that basically that
we would need to find out that this
entire story as it's being reported is
completely false and wrong and every
single aspect of it is fake I don't
think that's the case
especially when the the police
department itself is not saying that
they're the ones who came out and said
this was wrong this wrong this was wrong
he should have shot so I think we can be
pretty confident in the basics of the
case and and so I think we could say
that it was wrong at least now as for
the that's what they signed up for thing
I did make that argument but not in
reference to cops being killed I'm not
saying I'm okay with cops being killed
and I certainly would never dismissively
wave-off the death of police officers
with a statement like that I hope you
would know that I
there there there are people who do that
I wouldn't do that I'm not I'm not a I'm
not a psycho okay that would be crazy
that wasn't my point and would never be
my point and I agree that the anti cop
stuff in the media is overboard and
often dangerous and all this talk about
police officers you know hunting down
black people and murdering them that
talk is wrong and once again dangerous
and I've said that many times I have
made that point myself many times I said
again on Friday that I think the racial
angle in a lot of these cases is
overplayed certainly in this case I
don't think there's any reason to assume
that there was any real racial angle to
that even if the cop was white and the
the victim was black my only point with
that's what they signed up for was just
when it comes to a certain amount of
reasonable risk so I was specifically an
only taking issue with this attitude
that you encounter from some people that
basically excuses almost any cop
shooting if they can find some
technicality some way in which the
person who was shot may have been by
some very low percentage chance a risk I
gave the example of Daniel shaver in
Arizona I think it's one of the classic
examples tragic examples the man shot
and killed by cops while crawling on the
ground in a hotel hallway begging for
his life he was shot and killed by three
cops standing over him 10 feet away five
feet away with their cut with their guns
trained directly on him now he went and
reached for his waistband because his
pants were falling down he was trying to
pull them up it was just an instinctive
thing that's when they shot and killed
him
technically yes he moved his arm and so
technically maybe yeah you're allowed to
kill him and so that's why these cops
didn't end up going to jail even though
I think they should have I am taking
issue with that particular attitude
where you're saying that well
technically you know there's like a
point zero five percent chance that this
guy's actually a risk to you given given
the event that you have over him given
the fact that he is clearly making every
attempt to submit and he could not be
more submissive but there's still that
small tiny chance when he makes that
slight movement of his hand and so there
are some people who say well yeah you
know what
you can shoot them and okay better safe
than sorry in that kind of scenario I
find that sort of logic to be deeply
troubling my point is that the the
safety of police officers is of
tantamount importance also you know
period end of the sentence also the
safety of innocent civilians is also of
tantamount importance and so we should
not be putting the lives of police
officers over that of innocent community
members we should be putting the
community members over the police
officers you know I'm saying it's like
equal footing here so police officers
lives are very valuable the life of the
woman who was killed in her home at 2:00
a.m. while she was playing video games
with her with her nephew her life was
valuable too and that police officer's
life was not any more valuable than hers
and hers wasn't any more than him that's
my point I mean would you really take
issue with that but if we're gonna say
that in some way technically maybe that
believe that shooting was was justified
then I I don't see how you could do that
without without even if you don't say it
I don't see how you could make that
argument without essentially implying
that her life is not quite as valuable
and important as his because yeah maybe
technically somehow in some obscure
minor very small chance she coulda pose
a threat to him so just kill him just to
be safe I guess that's the that's my
problem this attitude of well kill the
civilian just to be safe just in case
and I know that no one is putting it
exactly like that but when you defend
things like the Daniel shaver killing or
when you potentially defend things like
this woman who was shot in their home at
2:00 a.m. Oh playing video games with
her nephew even if you're not saying
kill them just to be safe that is kind
of what you're saying and and I'm now
when I say you I don't mean necessarily
you specifically I'm talking to
Universal you so that's what that's my
that's my problem
i I and I think when
then I got a lot of emails on this so
this this is my one representative email
that I thought was reasonably written
and posed so I wanted to engage with it
but yes as I said there is it is not
true that there is an epidemic of cops
going around killing innocent people
that is that is not the case the
majority of cops are good people and
they're good at their job and they're
and they're just just like the majority
of anyone the majority of people in any
profession with the exception maybe of
you know drug lords the majority people
in any profession are you know they're
just trying to do their job and and
they're not all gonna be Saints they're
not all gonna be anything but but
they're trying to do their jobs and
they're trying to do a welding that's
the case for most people and that's the
case for most cops so yes however when a
civilian is gunned down unjustly by an
agent of the state I don't care if it
happens once a year or ten times a year
or a million times a year whatever the
exact frequency is not the point
when it happens when it whenever it
happens that is a huge injustice that is
the exact opposite of what is supposed
to be happening that is the exact
opposite of the relationship that is
supposed to be present between a citizen
and an agent of the state and so when
that happens we need to look at it we
need to analyze it we need to be
outraged by it because that person's
life does matter and and and we need to
look at what what could have possibly
led to that and I think that sometimes
yeah you are gonna look at you are there
general sort of attitudes present in
relation to law enforcement on law
enforcement that might provide
an environment where these kinds of
shootings will happen and I would say
that maybe there is sometimes so like I
said you know I appreciate the image but
some of the emails I got were so over
the top you know given the arguments
that I made which were pretty mild you
know if you listen to my and I know this
wasn't you but I'm talking to other
people that's an email if you listen to
to MOT what I said and came away with
I'm anti police or I hate police which
is a lot of the emails I got then you
just were not paying attention at all
because there's no way for an honest
person was paying attention to interpret
it that way just no possible way come on
or I have to assume that you'd really
don't care about the lives of these
people who are killed unjustly by police
not again not you but other other emails
I'd have to assume that that's the
impression again I'm not even reading
those emails because they pissed me off
so much I don't even know what I would
say on camera in response to them but
there are some people sent emails and it
really seems like they don't give a crap
for them it's just about the cop the
other person doesn't matter I I despise
that attitude just like I despise people
on the other side who don't care about
the lives of police officers I despise
both attitudes I think they're both
horrible all right let's see okay I
spent more time than I thought
will do one more this is from Henry says
hi Matt I just listened to your podcast
where you made the claim that every
person is a human and vice versa
although I agree with your stance on
abortion and I agree that a baby in the
womb is both a person and a human I
would have to disagree with that
statement
I've taught Bible studies on the Trinity
in the past and when I make the
statement that the Trinity consists of
three co-equal and coeternal persons I
always have to clarify that I'm not
saying the Trinity consists of three
humans each member of the Trinity is a
person because he is personal and as the
attribute of personhood I understand
this is not what you were talking about
so please forgive me if I'm being too
technical I'm pretty sure Henry I'd have
to go back and listen to it I'm pretty
sure I said that every human is a person
and that this distinction between
human and person is ad hoc it is an
artificial invented distinction invented
specifically to justify abortion because
there is no other time where a
pro-abortion person would draw a
distinction between human and person so
every human is a person that's my point
I didn't I don't think I said and if I
did that I was I was not phrasing it
correctly I don't think I said that
every person is a human because I agree
with you that's not true that's not
necessarily the case
there are ways of understanding person
that would not necessarily pertain to
humans though the word human always
pertains to people the word people
doesn't always pertain to humans so kind
of like every bourbon is a whiskey but
not every whiskey is a bourbon so every
human is a person not every person is a
human you gave one example another one I
would give as is you know in a sci-fi
scenario if intelligent life ever landed
on this planet in there UFOs and moved
in and started living with us all men in
black or something you I I think we
would have to say that they are people
they are persons they should be legally
granted as conscious sentient
highly-developed beings they should be
granted all the rights of people but
they're not human so and there are other
examples I mean corporations legally
count as as people which you know that's
it's a separate topic but the point is
legally whether we're talking legally
philosophically morally there could be
scenarios conceivable scenarios where a
nonhuman is a person or worried right
yes okay i phrase it right I'm confusing
myself but there is no scenario there is
no moral or philosophically justifiable
scenario where a human could be treated
like not a person though of course
legally that is a distinction we draw
which has enabled the murder of sixty
million persons through abortion alright
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer his Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena Matt
Walsh Oh is a daily wired production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 if you want
to delve the depths of leftist madness
head on over to the Michael Noel's show
where we examine what's really going on
beneath the surface of our politics and
bask in the simple joys of being right
[Music]